if the sirens weren't sounding already
when it comes to strikes they almost
certainly will be now ambulance work is
the first of the emergency services to
announce walkouts this winter with two
strikes planned either side of Christmas
affecting non-life-threatening calls
only
Simon's a paramedic and will join a
picket line in the West Midlands in 14
years in the job he says the pressures
have never been so great it's very much
like you've driven your ambulance into a
tunnel and there's no light at the end
of it the the the level of hopelessness
and the decrease in morale of staff
is just something that I have not seen
in my experience and many people who
have been in for a lot longer than I
have
haven't seen either like other disputes
this is about pay the three main
ambulance unions are demanding above
inflation pay hikes planning action that
affects all but one trust in England and
Wales Trade union rules mean that life
preserving care must still be provided
so things like Strokes heart attacks and
major trauma will still be responded to
but the exact details of this so-called
life and limb cover are yet to be
decided and it could mean that trips and
falls for example don't Merit a call out
for the elderly or for those who require
care it is a worrying Prospect Lisa
Roland suffered multiple strokes and
heart attacks in recent years but still
supports the strikes I don't know what
I'd do if it happened and I couldn't get
an ambulance that's scary but what can
we do I mean they need to do something
they don't get enough money I mean it's
ridiculous so even though you're worried
you still support their cause yeah
absolutely but instead of a countdown to
Christmas this is now a December of
disruption with industrial action of
some kind planned for almost every day
this month unions say it was a last
resort what people don't realize is that
the NHS is already crumbling beneath us
it's been a political decision to
deliberately underfund and
under-resource the NHS for the last
decade and one of the reasons our
members are taking this action is
because nobody is listening
the government's proposed a four percent
payoffer with health secretary Steve
Barkley calling the union demands
unaffordable all signs will be hoping
it's not patience paying the price
either Bennett Sky News